with this new approach that we have in
Palo proteomics and helped by Alpha fold
we can now look at very big evolutionary
questions potentially going back to
dinosaur times
in Australia there are thousands and
thousands of eggshells that are buried
in the sand these eggs were abundant for
many thousand years and then at some
point they disappeared because we're
finding burn marks on some of these
eggshells this implies that the eggs
have been processed and cooked so it is
possible that human consumption has
contributed to the demise of the species
for a long time these eggshells were
identified as belonging to a very big
extinct bird the bird goes under a
number of guises no Tony it's often
called a Thunderbird and then we have
this great name the demon deck of Doom
so the Thunderbird was a really large
flightless bird similar to an ostrich
and unlike nostridge there's a much
larger hair than a much larger beak
would have been pretty terrifying to
come across that late at night
but there were kind of two different
hypotheses so one group wanted to
believe that these eggshells belong to
this very large fossil of an extinct
type of bird or the alternative was it
was a much smaller bird a much less
impressive Bush turkey the eggshell was
fairly thin and the Egg itself would
have not been too big either the
question was
what sort of bird then was laying these
eggs and there was a big controversy
about this and we could solve it using
paloprotonics
is essentially the application of the
study of modern proteins but to ancient
ones found in fossils our colleagues
tried really really hard to get DNA out
of the eggshells they were not
successful because these are very old
specimens and the climate is very hot
and DNA degrades very quickly proteins
are actually a much more compact form of
information you need 16 amount of
molecules to give the same information
in proteins and DNA so it's small
compact and therefore survives longer
about 10 times longer than DNA in most
cases so the way we went about this was
to try and extract all the little bits
of proteins that are preserved in the
action we then put them together like in
a jigsaw puzzle we can then compare with
modern bird sequences and work out where
it fits in the bird family tree we have
the bird 10 000 Genome Project where we
have the AIM to sequence genomes for all
living bird species so we took the
protein sequence and we compared it to
our database of 363 birds so we were
doing our best to complete this jigsaw
puzzle and yet we couldn't quite decide
which one was the most correct until we
could actually look at the structure so
what we did is we took the sequence and
we ran it through Alpha fold because
we've been given all of these protein
sequences from other birds we could
start adding in the missing parts of the
protein to see how different bird
variants would actually reflect the
overall structural folding of the
protein what we found out was that it
was more likely that the eggs were laid
by these this very very large massive
Thunderbird and what that meant is that
the reason this bird goes extinct was
because of the desire for people to eat
the eggs so Alpha fold was used to solve
this big mystery that was incredibly
cool and I'm fairly sure this is the
first time that Alpha fold has been used
to study an extinct protein we are being
able now to start putting down the first
very accurate Strokes to this picture of
the past and Alpha fold is giving us a
three-dimensional view of what that past
might have looked like Alpha fold made
us think differently in effect